[Music]
in the wolf of wallstreet one of the
scenes that blew me away is Leonardo
DiCaprio's character and a lot of
characters in the film are are using
quaaludes they're using quaaludes and
there's a scene that's fantastic
where he's taken so many quaaludes that
he can't be understood right and I read
an awful it's true that you got a an
expert to come on the set and instruct
Leo about how one behaves when one has
had too many quaaludes is that correct
yes we did yes yes who's this I can't
say I can't say but I could put a few
words in there myself
you had a little experience yourself 35
years ago yeah you know I'm in a little
bit at that time they were legal and I
was I was actually prescribed a quaalude
for fear of flying and when you took
this pill it was like a five hour flight
whatever you took up you took that pill
you didn't care where you were you
didn't care and finally it wound down by
the time you landed thankfully because
you want it to you know hug everybody
and that sort of thing take a flight
with you when you're just hugging each
other you're crying
that sounds like fun but don't do it
kids or kids don't you always have to
put that into the app please